we I started going down this Rabbit Hole
of thinking about what is money when I
realized that I was in essence going to
lose my company
right and destroy the livelihoods of all
my employees and you know waste 30 years
of my life and so when I started
thinking about it and you know it's
helpful when Jerome Powell says we're
not even thinking about thinking about
raising interest rates you know your
strategy of investing in bonds is broken
when I started thinking about it what I
realized is money is energy
money is economic energy social
political energy currency is a medium
through which the energy moves
um
if if you wish to
um if you wish to hold energy and
transport energy you need a technology
we're not using gold anymore when we use
gold as I pointed out it's expensive and
it's uh and it's cumbersome
currencies don't work the US dollar is
the the strongest currency in the world
but is losing 15 to 20 percent of its
value a year the peso is losing 40 to 50
percent of its value a year the
boulevard is losing a hundred percent 95
98 of its value a year
so once you start thinking about it that
way you start thinking well what's a
better way to store economic energy
through time and you realize that
the currencies don't work gold doesn't
work so what is money well money money
in the last 30 years became the s p
index you buy a diversified portfolio of
companies of stocks which is a little
bit better
because maybe you're getting bled two
percent a year by the management team
but the company's making money and so
maybe you can hold value
it turns out that the money's losing
about 10 percent of its value a year and
the s p index is going up about 10
percent a year and you look at that for
a hundred years and there's a very
interesting correlation there
a diversified portfolio of assets is
tracking the money supply
okay interesting
what's the problem with that
well the problem with holding stocks as
a store of value is if the stock goes up
by a factor of 10 there's a management
team that has a fiduciary obligation to
issue more stock
there's a temptation to issue stock
stocks aren't scarce the the amount of
equity shares will also go up if the
stock is overvalued versus the
fundamentals of the company the CEOs
almost certainly going to issue more
stock and so that's one problem the
second problem is stocks have political
Nexus they have management teams they're
in countries they can be unionized I can
put a tariff on the product I've got a
competitor what if the CEO goes Bonkers
all sorts of interesting problems what
if the company gets expropriated by the
government you know or the jurisdiction
it operates Within
so stocks are an imperfect approach
better than gold the other approach is
by a bunch of buildings in New York City
by scarce desirable real estate in Miami
Los Angeles London
that's a an interesting idea and the
best idea in the 20th century if you're
gonna if you're going to try to either
create Walt or hold your wealth if you
want to hold your wealth you buy a
billion dollars worth of property if you
want to create wealth you borrow a
billion dollars and you buy a billion
dollars of property and you start with a
million dollars of equity a sliver of
equity and what you're doing is you're
going short the currency and you're
going long the property so if I told you
let's go to Argentina if I told you in
Argentina the peso is going to go from
one peso to the dollar to five pesos to
the dollar to 10 pesos to the dollar to
20 pesos to the dollar to 40 to 80 to
100 the black market rate right now is
210 pesos to the dollar
220. if I told you it was going to
collapse from 1 to 220
and you had 20 years of notice
what's your best strategy take your
million pesos convert it to Dollars and
you're going to have 220 million pesos
in 20 years you're going to look rich
better strategy is borrow a million
pesos convert to Dollars wow best
strategy would be mortgage your entire
company in pesos sell equity in your
company and pesos convert it all to
Dollars and then get dollars out of the
country
because if they're in the country if
you're if the million pesos is converted
to dollars in a bank in Argentina then
the government will basically pass a law
force your dollars to be converted back
into Pesos devalue them
and I happen to have some experience
with that because I actually had a
million dollars in Argentina during the
Lost currency collapse they converted to
pesos they devaluated ten to one a day
later I lost 90 percent of my money
so simple idea
short the currency which is collapsing
go long property and then get the
property out of the country
because the property in the country is
also going to devalue
because the property is valued based
upon the extreme of cash flows right if
the building is uh has got a a rent or
and it's got a lease and the lease is
capped at CPI or or denominated in local
currency when the currency collapses the
value of of the rental income also
collapses so
wouldn't it be great if I could buy a a
virtual building in Argentina
using borrowed pesos and then what if I
could Spirit the building out of the
country and rent it to people in London
or New York City
that's what Bitcoin is
Bitcoin is digital property
that you can teleport anywhere in space
instantly
and it's also perfected property with
with the lowest maintenance cost
you know you don't have the property tax
you have on a building you don't have to
repaint the thing every 10 years you
don't have to worry about leaks in the
roof
so if I could buy a big if I could buy a
billion dollars worth of property
and it was in cyberspace
and if you couldn't make any more of it
if I capped it at 21 million uh city
blocks in cyberspace
and if I could hold it for a thousand
years
I might have a better idea than buying a
city block in Manhattan or a building in
London
or even a company and it's a lot better
idea than buying 30 000 pounds worth of
gold
why because real estate developers going
to create more buildings Gold Miner is
going to create more gold Mayors are
going to pass a property tax and they're
going to they're going to put some kind
of uh
and joined or or some kind of
restriction on your rent rent control
your building
something you know acts of God are going
to create earthquakes and floods and
lightning strikes
and none of that stuff's happening in
cyberspace
so the whole idea of Bitcoin is
perfected engineered gold crypto gold
with none of the none of the defects of
gold you can't mine any more of it it's
it's weightless I can move it at the
speed of light it never decomposes
I can
break it into a thousand pieces in a
second send it to a thousand places and
recompose it uh all using a computer
program
and I can take personal custody of it
maybe the most the most powerful two
ideas are
I can hold possession of a billion
dollars of Bitcoin in my head
just holding a password or a set of
private Keys that's a pretty big idea
maybe the first the first time in the
history of the human race that you can
actually take possession of your wealth
and take it to the Grave with you or
take it anywhere else on Earth with you
and even if I put a gun to your head the
most I can do is kill you I can't take
it and this is a very interesting idea
every other form of property in the
history of the human race
I pulled a gun I get it all
right my incentive is to violence with
Bitcoin I pull the trigger I get none of
it
so the incentive is the negotiation I
would rather have half
than zero right and it's a very
interesting idea big idea and the second
big idea is super intimidated by the way
I'm
yeah I second big idea is it's a monitor
it's a virus
it's it's a cyber virus it's a it's a
chain reaction in cyberspace or it's a
life form in cyberspace
Bitcoin is a bank in cyberspace run by
Incorruptible software and the software
the software itself is gonna basically
protect your money the problem with
software is I don't trust the computer
it's on if it's on if it's on a single
phone I can seize the phone and
reprogram the software so if I came up
with the bank and a bank that was run by
software how do I prevent any human
being from corrupting it the thing that
makes it Incorruptible is I release
thousands tens of thousands or hundreds
of thousands of identical copies in
cyberspace and it's self-replicating and
all of the copies keep track of each
other and when one of them is corrupted
gets kicked off the network
so you could think of it as I released a
life form plankton
or a virus and I let it go
or a swarm now you're a part of the
swarm I shoot you it doesn't help you
have the genetic code I shoot you does
not I obliterate all of you know the the
algae in the Atlantic won't stop it I
eliminate all of the bacteria in your
body won't stop it right it's a virus
it's going to keep spreading and the
beauty of the system is
it's in essence this chain reaction in
cyberspace and the only purpose of the
chain reaction is to protect the
Integrity of the network
there will never be more than 21 million
Bitcoin so what you've got is is truth
and integrity released as a as a cyber
virus and you can if you choose to join
that Network you Avail yourself of all
of the benefits of that Network how many
of the 21 million Bitcoin have been been
mined already
about 18 and a half million so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye
[Music]